justin juste un mot évidemment on est
favorable à ce que tu viens de dire jean
charles il faut que l'accord
d'entreprise ce soit au coeur des choses
c'est vrai pour le temps de travail
c'est vrai pour les règles du travail
c'est vrai aussi pour le contrat de
travail l'entrepreneur doit être
sécurisé si on veut qu'ils quittent leur
bouche sinon ils n'embauchent pas assez
on assiste à cela aujourd'hui
mais il entreprises elles veulent aussi
de la stabilité elles veulent des règles
qui changent pas tout le temps elles
veulent qu'on s'occupe d'elle
enfin pas trop elles veulent surtout
s'occuper de leur propre entreprise et
donc on doit les mettre au centre de nos
de nos préoccupations sur le
licenciement évidemment il faut que les
motifs de rupture soit clairement
identifié d'un commun accord entre le
chef d'entreprise et puis le salarié
sinon il n'y a pas d'embauché et sur le
coût du travail
il ya des débats sur le coût du travail
on a essayé de le trancher en se disant
que le coût du travail doit baisser
d'abord sur le travail qui est pas
qualifié c'est là où elles potentiel
aujourd'hui d'emploi c'est là où au fond
le coût du travail est plus important
que la productivité de l'entreprise et
donc on propose de mettre notamment à 0
nicolas sarkozy l'a fait récemment mais
en tout cas de mettre un zéro les
charges leur est le reliquat de charge
il en reste même pas mal au niveau des
charges patronales sur le sur le smic et
puis on pense aux ménages employeurs les
ménages employeur c'est pas des
entreprises mais enfin ça y ressemble un
peu puisqu'elle ondes et des emplois et
on voit bien que depuis ces dernières
années les règles ont beaucoup bougé sur
la défiscalisation et et on voit bien
que ça crée du travail à douar et que ça
a créé beaucoup de chômage chez les
personnes qui peuvent être employés on
devra être là dessus aussi extrêmement
clair et avoir une politique régulière
entend en tout cas bien évidemment ce
que tu dis est être constitutif d'une
partie de notre notre projet le marché
du travail aujourd'hui il est trop
rigide et le contrat de travail
aujourd'hui il crée plutôt du chômage
qu'autre chose on doit sécuriser
évidemment les emplois par le biais de
la formation mais on doit pas évidemment
un sécuriser les entreprises car sinon
c'est les travailleurs qu'un paye les
pots cassés
merci eric